trente ans après la chute du mur de
berlin le monde se souvient la
réalisatrice franco allemandes katrin
vologe à vient de lancer un film sur le
sujet elle se rappelle des étés de sa
jeunesse passée à berlin-ouest tué
beaucoup de photos de ce mur là il y
avait et flore sommes à 17m fruits
j'avais pris cette photo là avec des
graffitis en jeu seraient exactement
locaux années 80 on a commencé à faire
des peintures des dessins des graffitis
à s'exprimer sur mur là je pense que
c'était thierry noir un français qui a
initié le mouvement
quelques jours après la chute du mur des
artistes de partout sur la planète se
sont emparés de la face est pour créer
la east side gallery à cette époque
magazine fête était à berlin
elle se souvient des films inspirés de
cette cicatrice dans la ville je pense
aux films d'espionnage des années 60
avec michael caine fiona roland debély
et là ils ont vraiment exploiter le mur
et je pense aux films de line dance et
de désir et ce sont deux anges qui se
promènent et qui passe le mur parce que
ce sont des anges que près de chez nous
il ya eu quand même
louis bélanger qui a fait un très beau
film gaz bar blues qui parlent de cette
époque avant la chute du mur berlin
ouest était une cité enclavée dans le
bloc de l'est mais aussi un incubateur
de création pour de nombreux artistes un
lieu plus libérale même que l'allemagne
de l'ouest était la fascination même
pour des jeunes et pour des artistes
autour des musiciens qui sont venus
habiter à berlin ouest
dans les années soixante dix comme
d'où certaines chansons sont devenues
emblématiques de la réunification des
deux allemagnes
al qods scorpions the wind of change le
clip a été tourné en 1990 et donc on a
intégré dans le vidéoclip des images de
la chute du mur de berlin de toute cette
jeunesse là qui célèbre la chute du mur
le mur de berlin est tombé
mais d'autres ont été érigés depuis ils
continuent eux aussi d'inspirer les
artistes
rafael lozano-hemmer crée actuellement
une oeuvre à la frontière
américano-mexicaine créer un pan de
lumière qui va traverser la frontière et
qui va du coup non seulement créer un
point de lumière mais un canal sonore à
défaut de faire tomber les murs l'art
peut initier le dialogue
il nous invitait à plus de fraternité
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal